yeah welcome to this video playing GUI
rip our query power okay yeah that's him
the Kings Indian ok let's see g4s the
most ambitious move
let's see what happens this g4 is some
interesting it's some a bit uncommon of
course for for this kind of Moloch's
abide structure the weird thing is from
blacks point of view the Queen on yet
but at least I played quickly okay
should I take I want to really now try
to get the bishop on c6
hmm now here yeah I don't think I should
don't have any substantial problems here
if I've looked what's very early it's
actually quite helpful that I'm able to
play Bishop to c6 and exchange a bit
here he also always needs to take into
account that is King side slightly
weakened
yeah just take at quincy say change so
simple and good i hope so just talk the
ATM using the pin
yeah I think Bishop f6 know anything
else looks really strange but I'm
threatening e6 no it's quite a
substantial threat okay I'm just on c5
was my plan at least
check yeah hmm maybe I'm I
underestimated this a bit hmm yeah he's
got some activity the rook here
yeah maybe just this one yeah it took a
bit of time it's a it's just I can
choose between various various lines
that are all a bit worse
hmm ok but if he takes
what doesn't not not easy at all
look at 7i of Quincy seven I hope to get
the Queen back riya yr b 6 somewhere b6
rocky g7 I can play look good eight
probably oh this is surprising look I
walk dat can play look f seven
I know after I have 27 let's not let's
not lose episode yeah but then look at
the age should really help him broke a
leg I have this one sec aah aah 24 I
forgot about that oh what a move check
oh all right black resigns
yeah and that means it's totally busted
it is already busted here and even here
so be five losses due to ya b3 also wins
but this complicated move also wins can
now I need to play the the modest Queen
c6 suffering in this crap position check
ah wow I'm such a [ __ ] why did I take
here
it's just this automatic move like just
take it check just take it I can't
simply play King g7 and I'm just better
in this position I completely overlooked
that him this is just good for black
there's a strong bishop on f6 why would
I take it hmm what I said he can take
here but through p8 young can play this
is so almost trapped here we can play
any kind of move b2 is just still
hanging also here yeah this is at least
ha better than the game the computer
actually gives me a big edge already
right which I cannot completely
understand maybe it is very concrete
that I get the beep own but this is like
miles better than the game of course
yeah I didn't think you had just played
this instantly and thought I writer I
find something but there's nothing to
find and this is this is busted i cannot
defend it there's also the best move
yeah this isn't made huh yeah he
executed this nicely after my mistake
but before here he needs to take f6 no
it's better check and King g7 arm wow
what a howler to take on his head yeah
it's a bit of thing is it's an
instructive moment you really feel if
you are confronted with the check and
you can easily break it with taking it's
not automatically the best move I mean
this is clear in a way it's not a
revolutionary thing to say but still
sometimes you just have this reflex like
take it but it's it's really bad here no
yeah thanks for watching